♪ ♪
>> Hannity: THE BIDEN ECONOMY
IS GOING FROM BAD TO US AND SOME
COUNTRY IS FACING THE
POSSIBILITY OF THE DIESEL
SHORTAGE THIS WINTER AND A REAL
POSSIBILITY THAT HEATING BILLS
COULD SPIKE NORTH OF 30%
ESPECIALLY IN THE NORTHEAST THIS
WINTER, AS BIDEN'S ENERGY
POLICIES CRIPPLE OUR SECURITY.
LOOK AT THIS REPORT FROM
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," EVEN
WARMING TONIC WARNING OF WINTER
BLACKOUTS ACROSS NEW ENGLAND ALL
BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN, HE'S
ECONOMIC AND ENERGY POLICIES,
AND OF COURSE HIS EFFORTS TO
ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE THE WORLD
SUPPLY OF ENERGY IN ORDER TO LET
THE GREEN NEW DEAL GO FORWARD.
THE DOW TANKED AGAIN TODAY AFTER
JEROME POWELL JEROME POWELL
ANNOUNCED ANOTHER FOUR IN A ROW
NOW 75 BASIS POINT INCREASE RATE
HIKE.
MEANING NOW IT'S GONNA COST EVEN
MORE UP TO BUY A NEW HOME OR
USED ON THAT'S FOUR MONTHS IN A
ROW I'M A MASSIVE INCREASE IN
INTEREST RATES.
WHAT IS WILL IT MEAN TO YOU?
A MONTHLY MORTGAGE PAYMENT OF AN
8% RATE, A 30-YEAR RATE, WOULD
BE A WHOPPING $300 MORE A MONTH
AND A 7% INCREASE OF 30 YEARS,
AROUND A THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE
EVERY SINGLE MONTH WHEN YOU
COMPARE IT TO THE RATES UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHICH WERE WELL
UNDER 3%.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
WE GO FROM AN AVERAGE OF 2.7%, A
LITTLE UNDER 3% FOR A 30-YEAR
FIXED-RATE MORTGAGE.
NOW YOU PAY 12,000 MORE PER YEAR
OVER 30 YEARS.
THAT'S A WHOPPING $360,000 MORE
FOR A $500,000 HOME OVER 30
YEARS WITH A 30-YEAR FIXED-RATE
MORTGAGE.
SO LET'S BE CLEAR.
WHEN I HEADED TOWARD 8% FOR A
30-YEAR FIXED.
I WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IF
DOUBLE-DIGIT RATES ARE NOW IN
THEIR FUTURE AND ALL OF THAT IS
ADDED TO THE SURGEON BIDEN
INFLATION.
YOU HAVE RISING PRICES
EVERYWHERE FROM THE GAS STATION,
THE GROCERY AISLE, SINKING STOCK
MARKET, EVERYONE'S 401(K)s ARE
SUFFERING, ALL CAUSED BY
JOE BIDEN, HIS ECONOMIC AND ITS
ENERGY PROBLEMS.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE'S RESPONSES
TO MISLEAD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
EVEN MORE.
THE WHITE HOUSE DELETED THIS
TWEET TODAY TOUTING AN INCREASE
TO SOCIAL SECURITY CHECKS AFTER
TWITTER FACT-CHECKED THE POST
EXPLAINING, THE ONLY REASON THE
PAYMENTS ARE GOING UP ARE
BECAUSE OF BINDS INFLATION IN
THE COST-OF-LIVING ADJUSTMENTS.
THIS IS WHY I CANNOT CONVEY MY
FULL URGENCY IN WORDS ABOUT HOW
CRITICAL AND CRUCIAL THIS
ELECTION REALLY IS.
HEREWITH REACTION IS
FOX BUSINESS HOST CHARLES PAYNE.
SEE A PINK 2.7% FOR 30-YEAR
FIXED-RATE MORTGAGE, IT'S OVER
7% FOR TODAY 75 BASIS POINT
INCREASE.
I DO THE MATH, LAID IT OUT.
$500,000 HOME IS NOT ACCOSTING
DRAMATICALLY MORE FOR A FAMILY.
NOW WE HAVE A HOUSING RECESSION
MEANING NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION
HAS STOPPED, PRE-EXISTING HOMES
HAVE STOPPED SELLING, HOME
VALUES ARE DETERIORATING ALONG
WITH YOUR 401(K)s.
HOW DOES THAT STOP?
>> IT WON'T STOP FOR A LONG
TIME.
THAT'S WHAT WE LEARNED TODAY
FROM CHAIRMAN POWELL.
WE'VE GOT TO GO BACK TO HOW THIS
HAPPENED AND WHY THIS HAPPENED.
IT'S TOO MUCH MONEY.
TOO MUCH MONEY WAS POURED INTO
THIS ECONOMY.
WE HAD $7.3 TRILLION FROM BOTH
ADMINISTRATIONS.
ANYONE WHO TRIES TO CONFLATE
WHAT HAPPENED ON 2020, WHEN YOU
STOP THE ENTIRE ECONOMY, TOLD
PEOPLE HE CAN GO TO WORK,
BUSINESSES THEY COULD NOT OPEN,
THE ENTIRE WORLD THAT THAT I'M A
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED IN 202011.
THAT'S BEING DISINGENUOUS.
THE POINT IS THAT ALL THAT MONEY
THAT CAME IN IN 2021 IS THE
SPARK.
IT'S PART TWO THINGS.
THIS RUNAWAY INFLATION, AND NO
WAGE SPIRAL.
WHEN YOU PAY PEOPLE NOT TO WORK,
THEY MAKE TWICE AS MUCH STAYING
AT HOME EATING FROOT LOOPS IN
THE TWO GOING TO WORK,
BUSINESSES GET DESPERATE AND
HAVE TO RIDGE OF WAGES.
THAT'S UNCONTROLLABLE NOW.
THE FEDERAL RESERVE IS TRYING TO
DOUSE THIS.
I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF WHAT
THEY'RE DOING BUT I ADMIT THEY
HAVE TO DO THIS TO A DEGREE.
WHAT'S MAKING IT EVEN TOUGHER IS
PRESIDENT BIDEN STILL POURING
MONEY INTO THE ECONOMY.
SOME PEOPLE LEARN THE GETTING
CHECKS FOR COLLEGE LOAN
FORGIVENESS.
BY THE WAY, THESE ARE THE ELITES
OF THE ELITE.
DON'T MAKE ANYWHERE FROM ONE TO
$3 MILLION MORE, MORE, THAN THE
AVERAGE PERSON IN AMERICA.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE STATE WHERE
MORE THAN 50% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE THERE HAVE BACHELOR'S
DEGREE.
SO THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS ARE
PAYING, SUBSIDIZING THE ELITES.
LET ME SHARE IT DEVIN ASKEW ONE
THING.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
PRESENT BIDEN TRYING TO PASS THE
BUCK WITH RESPECT TO OIL
COMPANIES.
I JUST WANTED TO HEADLINES FOR
YOU.
ONCE FROM FEBRUARY 21ST OF THIS
YEAR.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FREEZES
FRACKING AFTER ITS REVEALED
ABOUT THE SOURCE OF CARBON.
ONE OF THE DUKE QUESTION MIKE
THEY HALTED ALL THE LEASES.
LET'S GO TO ANOTHER HEADLINE,
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
OCTOBER 28TH, INHERITED JUST
RECENTLY.
BIDEN KNOWS HIS POLICIES
INCREASE AVERAGE ACCOUNTS FOR
AMERICANS.
WHERE DID THEY GET THIS
EVIDENCE?
THE APARTMENT OF THE INPUT ON
THE FIVE HER PAGE REPORT.
WHO'S GONNA READ IT, RIGHT?
INSIDE THAT REPORT, THEY ADMIT
THAT ALLOWING ALL LEASES WOULD
REDUCE THE COST OF OIL AND GAS,
ALL BY $0.73 A GUESS BY $0.06.
THERE HURTING THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC AND THEY NEED TO KNOW
THIS, THE AMERICAN PUBLIC,
WHETHER GOING OUT THERE AND
BLAMING OIL COMPANIES AND
PROFITS BECAUSE THAT'S A AN
ATTACK ON CAPITALISM.
>> Hannity: POWELL PUT A WET
BLANKET ON ANY IDEA THAT WE HAVE
A SOFT LANDING IN TERMS OF THE
ECONOMY TODAY.
>> POWELL WAS UPSET.
[LAUGHS]
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING, FIRE
WAS COMING OUT OF HIM.
HE SAID, LOOKING UP POUND THIS
ECONOMY.
WHEN WE CRUNCH THE NUMBERS IN
SEPTEMBER, THE CRITICAL HIGHER.
THIS IS THE WORST SINGLE DAY
REVERSAL IN A FED DAY IN
HISTORY.
WE WERE UP INITIALLY, WE CREATED
IN THE CLOSING, THE ONLY THING
THAT CAUSED DUMB NECK IT WAS THE
CLOSING BELL GRID POWELL WAS
BREATHING FIRE.
HIS JOB IS INSURMOUNTABLE AND HE
WILL BECOME A PUBLIC VILLAIN, HE
KNOWS IT AND THERE'S NOTHING HE
CAN DO.
MODERN MONETARY THEORY, FREE
MONEY CURES EVERYTHING, RIGHT?
IT WAS GENDER JUSTICE,
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE RACIAL
JUSTICE.
ALL AND DONE EYES MAKE THE
POOREST AMERICANS POORER.
POWELL IRONICALLY SAYS HE'S
GOING AFTER EXCESSIVE SAVINGS.
POOR PEOPLE DON'T HAVE EXCESSIVE
SAVINGS.
>> Hannity: BUCKLE UP, IT'S
JUST PROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
THE POOR AND IT'S ALSO IMPACTING
70% OF THE COUNTRY THAT ARE NOW
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
MANY PEOPLE